und ich möchte heute ein video machen in
enna games durch euch meine also die
zwei besten kids vorstelle
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde ender
games mal wieder von mir diese mono
braun lächelt auch schon an ich bin ein
bisschen angeschlagen das liegt nicht
daran dass ich krank bin oder so sondern
ganz einfach weil ich gerade vier
stunden mai kräftig mit goma aufgenommen
habe ich glaube sondern mich an ihrem
stück aufgenommen aber es war so geil
werden so spaß dabei das cool ist glaube
ich die beste aufnahme geworden die ich
in meinem leben gemacht habe weil wir
seine ganze zeit am lachen und haben
erfolge geschafft und alles möglich auch
richtig richtig geil und ich möchte
heute ein video machen in enna games
durch euch meine also die zwei besten
kids vorstelle das ist allerdings meine
ansicht zu zeitig auf meinen kopf das
ist meiner ansicht also es kann sein
dass er sagt ach ich finde die katze und
den dingsda viel besser und den dieb und
acht keine ahnung was aber den techniker
und dem ziel super finde ich auch gut
und blabla ist eure sache das sind meine
ich finde das sind für mich die zwei
besten kids da steht in meinem titel von
meinem video deswegen sind für mich die
beiden besten kids wir gehen einfach mal
in welche lobby gehen benennen ich
möchte mich irgendwie desert oder so wir
gehen einfach mal ein planes und zwar
das erste ist ziel sucher wir nehmen
kurzer suche beschreibung als ziel
sucher solltest du einfachen spielern
die ab horn hinterherkommen sobald ein
spieler an deiner umgebung weniger als
50 prozent leben hat das viereinhalb
herz oder weniger bekommst du also ich
selbst dreimal so schnellen speed und
zweimal +2 schaden den ich aus teile
oder halt ein stecke außerdem starte ich
mit gold schon mit einem gold schwert
das heißt habe direkt am anfang zwei
waffen falls sich nichts
zwei ungespielt sehr schön falls ich
nicht irgendwie einer kiste bekommen
oder so es geht auch direkt los und ich
nehme die runden das ist eine aufnahme
ich mache ich werde das nicht irgendwie
sagen okay kommt die runde
wahrscheinlich was normal war ich bin
real wenn das café war nämlich dass auch
deswegen
es wäre vielleicht sinnvoller den shader
auspackt allerdings sieht das ganze dann
ein bisschen drüber aus ich packe es
allerdings mal den shader obwohl ich
finde einfach ich finde shader gehört
sich nach der shader schönen lassen wir
mal drin
es läuft bei mir wie auch flüssiger mit
shader das ist sehr sehr komisch
vielleicht muss ohne shader dann erst
mal die welt irgendwie nur aufgebaut
werden keine ahnung so es geht los ich
hoffe ich werde mich noch mal voll
getauscht also das ist ziel sucher das
heißt ich dir einfach direkt auf andere
es kann sein dass die länder minute
sterben aber ich nehme die augen aber
dann trotzdem
ok ich hab keinen sachen ich habe zwei
gold- okay das war echt kacke so da
hinten sehe ich aber schon eine kiste
die erste ok direkt drei eisen okay das
ist gut dann kann ich mir schon mal
eisenstadt machen so kommen bringen wir
schneller da hinten hin so schnell zu
den bäumen
ich hatte ja auch immer die leute ich
hab vorhin schon ein paar runden probe
gespielt einfach so ein paar kids
auszutesten
ich hatte ja immer die leute ich dachte
stehen kiste ich hatte ja diese leute
das bak übrigens bis zum 10 ich hasse
übrigens diese leute ich denke ich mal
vom klima ab ich hatte übrigens diese
leute die wurde dich einfach dann wenn
du getauscht wird und die haben sich
einfach so einen riesigen turm gebaut
und du bist einfach auf diesem turm und
denkst dino sofa okay man sprintet ja
die meiste zeit endlich einmal games
weil man die ganze zeit so richtig unter
druck steht und deswegen guck ich habe
zum beispiels weise auch noch 30
sekunden
weil man immer so richtig unter druck
steht und die sache ist einfach dass man
dann von diesem hohen turm halt
runterfällt wo man es einfach tot
man fällt dann von oben runter denkt
sich so geil okay was soll das wie das
schwein das schaf explodiert ist das
eigentlich auch ein effekt
ja stimmt die stehe ja das stimmt muss
explodieren auch das habe ich mit
bekommen das ist nämlich ganz gut wenn
ein leute verfolgen
genau das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen
dass stand auch gar nicht oder da statt
nur wenn die 50 weniger schaden haben
dann mache ich mehr power
die schutzzeit ist zu einem ok man kann
jetzt mal bescheid gucken 78 blöcke da
heißt ich schnappe mir noch eben hier
die kiste ok ich kann mir schuhe kräften
daneben da zurück ich merke schon da
sind wir welche am rücken 63 56 okay ist
ich entferne mich gerade wieder so
schnell schuhe kräften
jetzt bauen wir gucken da habe ich was
zu fressen
da hinten ist aber der bringt mir gar
nichts vielleicht kann ich meine pilz
schale machen daraus kommen andere pilze
raus kommen hier an opel aus doch das
essen okay gut so ist man im ok laufen
laufen laufen laufen laufen 39 36 glaube
da kommt jemand hinterher 30 31 ich
verstecke mich mal eben ganz kurz ich
glaub dahin ist einer irgendwo ich will
am liebsten diesen tieren bleiben weil
ich die ganzen tiere töten kann
und dann explodieren die halt wissen
aber da hinten ist auch gerade sonne
kiste die guckt mich wundervoll an ihr
wisst ich bin nicht so ganz gut im pvp
deswegen für mich wäre einfach mal ein
podium spot ist schon super ich höre
jemand diese tausch geräusche so ich
besonders erst ein bisschen speed hier
so
25 schnelligkeit darum es auch noch
einer
aber das bringt gar nicht so viel auf
einmal so wo sind hier noch welche 62
okay ich nähere mich jemandem ich nähere
mich immer ich glaube ich töte x ein
paar tiere und packt ihr einfach
irgendeine verzauberung drauf 84 blöcke
wieder nur so besteht auch noch eben
noch ein bisschen mehr jungs 110 alter
will keiner zu mir kommen sechs blöcke
ok 11 15 ich entferne mich jetzt mal
wieder zurück ok erstmal was fressen
alter alter geht auch im eishockey ist
okay sagt mir fast kein schaden
ach so das war war ich wahrscheinlich
durch das kit nämlich hab ich dann
doppelte power bekommen dann war sie
direktorin einfach okay das war ganz gut
ich wollte ich kann mir helm kräften
dafür brauche ich mir eben crafting
table argument sind wir hier wieder oder
ist dass das ich bin immer total dabei
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich so
lange noch überlebe dass der schaffe
hier unten denkt man sich immer so man
safe aber ich würde auch einfach die
ganze zeit kompass ich brauche meine ich
kann mir selbst ein kräften ebene
ich wollte ja gerade schon getauscht oh
mann ich erschrocken
doch woran ich mich erschrocken brauche
ich mich erschrocken habe ich dem
spieler eine kiste
ich höre ich hoffe schritte schritte 21
blöcke anders irgendwie hinter mir da
ist jemand
oh mein gott online oppidum war das denn
hat volle leben ich weiß es gar nicht
acht takte der musik mich sogar ohne er
sieht mich sogar ohne dings acht das ist
cool man kann gar nicht so nah
heranfliegen
ach man mit skill place es ist nur ein
spiel musst jetzt nicht so soll das ist
ja der mich getötet hat
fick dich ja ich nehme die runde kein
ding
ich wollte nur die klasse zeigen dass es
richtig cool garantiere in eine wieso
bin ich nicht zu den tieren gelaufen
aber ich bin ja auch dahin gelaufen und
alles und acht mann egal das war auf
jeden fall klassen nummer eins die ich
euch euer ich würde direkt runter gehen
sollte
das war klasse nummer eins ich euch
vorstellen wollte ich geh mal wieder die
style & lobbying spieler verstecken so
also nächster halt endlich weitergehen
jetzt kommt die klasse nummer zwei dann
nehme ich mal tiger hills und zwar ist
es da techniker der als techniker
bekommst du immer bessere rüstung und
waffen wenn du einen anderen spieler
getötet hat allerdings ist eine rüsten
debatte die möglichkeit die man sich gar
nicht warte ich mache ich dann die da
genau erwartet und zwar der dieb das
weiß ich so da der dieb kann ender
kisten diese kisten die da immer
auftauchen direkt richtig drauf und ist
direkt ausgeleert quasi wie bei
irgendwelchen die bei travel and travel
terroristen wie babbel michael krappel
main will damals einfach rechts klicken
zack habe ich den inhalt so stelle ich
mir das geht auf jeden fall vor ich habe
mir die ganzen beschreiben dadurch
gelesen das sollte sich auch im kurzen
an also die und die piep piep und ziel
sucher für mich sind die alle gehalten
das sind die zwei besten kids in meinen
augen sind das beides die geilsten kids
in ender games mittlerweile und das ist
die mit denen ich immer spiele wenn ich
da spiele spiel das ja manchmal so
nebenbei selten aber manchmal spiele ich
das und ich weiß nicht ob ich schon am
sport funktioniert ist das ja auch
gerade von den beschreibungen her sind
die geilsten alter es hat einfach nicht
geklappt
oh mein gott okay vielleicht klappts
baiersbronn kiste nicht muss man ganz
kurz gucken
ich nehme direkt die analogie nach
dahinten wohin er hat das schon
superwurf locker darüber richtig gut da
so erstmal kurz holz holen dann macht
man eisen schwert soll das ist der plan
so dass auch immer also dieser standard
move in meinem workbench machen so zack
zack zack ein schwert so ein scheitern
war so und jetzt müssen wir mal ganz
kurz schauen ob wir immer noch links
haben wie immer noch kisten finden weil
das das wärs wenn das jetzt eben wie gar
nicht geklappt hätte mit dem etikett
auswahl oder so 130 sekunden
hallo kisten ich finde einfach gar keine
kisten wahrscheinlich an leute die hier
gerade zuschauer habe ich wieder längst
leiche gefunden
das schon wir die welt zu ende
wie soll ich den kisten finden
das ist zwar ok jetzt funktioniert
irgendwie nicht ich weiß nicht wo das
nicht geht wahrscheinlich habe ich etwas
falsch gemacht da seiner in zehn zwölf
blöcke hinter mir ich könnte mir so
coole sache machen
oh mein gott sie tötet mich einfach was
er für eine kacke
das ist das funktioniert nicht richtig
und wie sie hat die volle rüstung
aber er gibt dir jetzt komm bitte töte
sie ja ok sie ist oder ich weiß gar
nicht wie dumm waren das kit also
wirklich ich habe die ganzen kids ich
kann ja nicht alle kids auf einmal
testen aber von der beschreibung herd
war das so dass ich einfach nur recht
auf eine kiste machen muss und dann habe
ich die wahrscheinlich muss man ihnen
die taste drücken es tut mir leid falls
das jetzt irgendwie falsch angewendet
habe aber an sich wäre das so mein mann
mein lieblingsding gewesen
ich kann mir noch mal ein paar mehr kids
durchlesen kurz da steht doch der dieb
kalender kisten mit einem klick komplett
leeren und ich habe einfach drauf
geklickt mit rechts mit links dicken
hals funktionierte nichts also keine
ahnung was ich nicht also wenn das
irgendwie funktioniert dann wäre das auf
jeden fall mein lieblingskind weil ich
finde in enna games hast immer sein
stress und muss dann immer rechtzeitig
auf in welche kisten machen alles raus
ziehen und alles und das ist super wenn
du einfach recht sagt du hast du da hat
ist die nächste zeit einfach mitnehmen
und das alles im inventar das wär super
coole wird eine menge zeit sparen gerade
bei seinem stressigen modus vivendi
games und ziel suche halt habe ich sogar
noch dazu erfahren dass wenn man tiere
schlägt das die explodieren da stelle
ich mir richtig cool verwender in einer
verfolgt muss man einfach warten
tötet man das schwein und ein
explodierter also dass er auf jeden fall
richtig cool wenn ihr in der games
selber spielen wollt dann geht einfach
auf die alb in der beschreibung ich
wollte ich einfach mal zeigen weil ich
oft gefragt werde ja mit welchem kind
spielzimmer intelligenz und bring mal
wieder ändern games habe ich ja zwei
runden gebracht ich bin scheiße ich bin
schlecht im pvp deswegen bringe ich das
auch nicht so oft sondern die beiden
siege oder so eine kacke die runde
beginne ich möchte gern mitspielen und
deswegen spielt das nicht auf euch
einfach kein pvp bin allerdings habt ihr
mich gefragt was sind meine lieblings
kids kids und das sind definitiv die
pänz funktionieren wird und viel suche
auf jeden fall ist mein absolutes
lieblings kit und deswegen würde ich
auch sagen freunde wenn es euch gefallen
hat könnt ihr dem video gern einen
daumen hoch gehen das wird mich freuen
und wenn ihr mehr ändern games volt
vielleicht einmal so dass sich nur die
besten rund nehmen dass ich so mehrere
aufnehme und dann schlage ich nur die
besten rein oder irgendwie so dann
schreibt man einfach in die kommentare
ich bin ja gar produzieren das video
wenn alles geklappt hat könnt ihr mal
kontrollieren wenn alles geklappt hat
kommt das video gerade an
31 17 ich bin richtig krass am
vorproduzieren er das ist so heftig und
ja gut ich mag euch alter was schreibt
ihr denn alle schreiben einfach ein herz
die dressen alle total aus du kannst
ich bin richtiger gast genau egal ich
will euch sagen schönen tag und schießen